tf1 20 heures avec roger gicquel iran se
seraient officiels l'ayatollah khomeini
part demain pour terran réquisitoire de
françois mitterrand contre la politique
économique du chef de l'état le parti
socialiste présentera en avril un
contre-plan la réduction des dépenses de
santé
demain au conseil des ministres deux
cibles les hôpitaux la surconsommation
de médicaments 13 réfugiés espagnols
interpellés au pays basque français
une mesure qui devrait être bien
accueillie à madrid et bien justement ne
sais pas du tout si l'ayatollah khomeini
partira ou ne partira pas demain nous en
sommes en effet encore ce soir à une
sorte de valse hésitation au sujet de
l'ayatollah khomeiny et de son départ
pour l'iran sans arrêt reporter je vous
le rappelle depuis une semaine prévu
fermement très fermement vendredi
dernier puis dimanche par l'intéressé
réclamé par presque tout son peuple
reporter jour après jour parce que
l'actuel gouvernement iranien avait fait
fermer les aéroports
mais ce soir tout de même les choses ont
beaucoup évolué d'abord et c'est ça
l'essentiel c'est ça la grande nouvelle
le gouvernement iranien réunis en
conseil des ministres a accepté qu'un
avion d'air france transportant
l'ayatollah khomeiny et son entourage
puissent atterrir demain dans la journée
à téhéran
la compagnie air france a reçu elle
aussi ce feu vert mais à
neauphle-le-château aucune décision
n'était encore prise il ya une demi
heure il est clair que pour l'ayatollah
khomeini la décision de partir pour
téhéran ne doit appartenir qu'à lui seul
ce retour de l'ayatollah et
naturellement capital pour la suite des
événements en iran
voyons où nous en sommes maintenant à
neauphle le château avec jean-loup
demigneux mais roger gicquel
si effectivement été rédac on est
d'accord même si la france est prêt ici
à neauphle-le-château aucun préparatif
pour un départ cette nuit rien
d'officiel mais très vraisemblablement
l'ayatollah et son entourage ne
partiront que demain soir en fait il ya
sans doute à cela trois raisons la
première est que l'ayatollah khomeiny et
vous le disiez n'est pas
à attendre attendre un feu vert du
conseil des ministres de l'iran la
deuxième raison est que l'ayatollah
souhaite arriver avant la prière de midi
or s'il était parti cette nuit à 5
heures du matin demain et bien
l'ayatollah sera arrivé trop tard et il
aurait rentrera t sont sa rentrée en
iran après 15 ans d'exil
et puis la troisième raison est que la
nouvelle n'a été connue à téhéran que
vers 8h 8h30 du soir et bien sûr demain
la population la foule n'aurait pas eu
le temps d'être mobilisés ce sont les
trois raisons que l'on voit ici à
neauphle le château pour expliquer le
désir de l'ayatollah khomeini de ne
rentrer que demain alors que depuis
effectivement une semaine il ne cesse de
nous dire dès que je le pourrai dès que
techniquement cela sera possible nous
rentrerons alors à téhéran on n'a pas
signalé d'autres violences aujourd'hui
que l' incendie d'une brasserie par des
manifestants chiites mais il règne
toujours une sorte d'anarchie
teheran les grandes villes semblent être
toujours au bord de la guerre civile les
événements d'hier incendies dans les
quartiers réservés
lynchage d'un général de gendarmerie
font craindre le pire aux étrangers le
gouvernement américain a donné l'ordre
d'évacuation temporaire à toutes les
familles de ces fonctionnaires ans nous
avons je dirais la chance parce que les
communications ne sont pas faciles
d'abord en ligne notre correspondant
perd 20 notre envoyé spécial robert
bouchard atterrant alors robert comment
ça se passe là bas d'abord ce retour de
l'ayatollah la décision politique prise
aujourd'hui comment l'interprétez vous
convenir cet après midi le premier
ministre au japon barre car la qualité
est retourné les militaires n'arrêtait
pas d'entrer et sortir de son palais on
s'attend décision soit prise
apparemment les discussions ont été
difficiles pour un
le retour de l'ayatollah dans bien que
dans maintenant que 20 kg très réussi à
les convaincre
alors évidemment ici que les choix et
les cris de joie ont vaincu aura été
rompues l'émission pour annoncer la
nouvelle
et il ya déjà exactement 2 minutes
prenant pas encore de réaction populaire
robert bussière que vous parliez nous
voyons des images assez violente sur les
manifestations qui je pense sont d'hier
notamment des incendies
est ce qu'il ya eu aujourd'hui un
incident semblable est-ce qu'on est au
bord de la guerre civile comme on
commence à le dire après franchement
depuis trois jours ça prenait
franchement allures de guerre civile est
probable
alors robert richard
robert richard
deux jours précédents il ya jacques
moret qu'elle incendies et forêts c'est
comme un sens à sa copine hyperion
policiers dans les rues jamais on a
attaqué général on a sorti de sa voiture
on l'a traîné sonnée par les cales des
rôles à l'ag amour est dans le coma
intérieur de la gendarmerie
ensuite on a pris les modalités des
motocycles armées reconnaît là j'ai
aussi les on a mis le feu à leur vie y
avait une espèce de montée de violence
et y avait tout un endroit où tout
autour de la nuit bien robert bichet jeu
la communication est parfois très coupé
nous avons beaucoup de marques comprend
nous avons quand même compris je crois
l'essentiel
je pense que vous n'avez plus rien à
dire sur cette situation en iran merci
robert
je vous rappelle pour mémoire la grève
de 24 heures demain dans les banques à
l'appel des cinq organisations
syndicales de cinq organisations
syndicales les salaires les conditions
de travail et l'insuffisance des
effectifs sont les motifs de cette grève
dans les banques qui va sans doute
beaucoup perturbé le fonctionnement des
guichets et retardé les opérations
bancaires et puis c'est justement la fin
de mois et puis on connaît maintenant la
date de la grève générale dans la
sidérurgie décidé par l'ensemble des
syndicats ce sera le 16 février
une précision force ouvrière n'appelle à
la grève que dans les bassins de l'est
et du nord de son côté le conseil
régional du nord-pas-de-calais envoyé un
télégramme au premier ministre
aujourd'hui en lui demandant instamment
d'intervenir auprès du sinn or pour
éviter les suppressions d'emplois à
denain compte tenu de la situation
dramatique du valenciennois
sans attendre la grève nationale du 16
février
les militants syndicaux et les groupes
d'ouvriers continuent leurs actions
spectaculaires selon la tactique adoptée
depuis une quinzaine de jours et cette
tactique a lieu tous les jours à denain
aujourd'hui dans le nord comme à longwy
dans l'est les protestations les plus
vives ont traduit l'angoissent des
licenciements et se sont exprimées par
des occupations de gare des barrages sur
les routes ce matin sur l'autoroute de
bruxelles est plus grave à longwy très
tôt ce matin les forces de l'ordre sont
intervenues à l' usine de la chiers pour
libérer le directeur et deux de ses
collaborateurs retenus dans leurs
bureaux par 150 ouvriers
les policiers de longueuil ont fracturé
la porte à la hache qui a eu des
affrontements
sept policiers ont été légèrement
blessés un autre est à l'hôpital et dans
l'après midi les ouvriers sidérurgistes
pénétré en force dans les locaux du
commissariat de longwy
cette fois ils étaient environ 400 ils
ont brisé plusieurs portes du
commissariat renversé des voitures en
stationnement
les policiers ont riposté à coups de
grenades de grenades lacrymogènes une
fois de plus on constate à quel point le
climat est tendu dans ces régions
françois go wi de jour en jour les
tensions s'aggrave et se multiplient en
lorraine et dans le nord-pas-de-calais
longwy nouvelle manifestation cet après
midi cette fois pour protester contre
l'intervention de la police
après l'occupation de l'usiné de la
chiers la nuit dernière des heurts
violents opposent manifestants et forces
de l'ordre
rumba toujours en lorraine ce matin le
trafic ferroviaire est interrompu
metz une cinquantaine de mineurs de
faire bloc et les charges un train de
minerais mauritanien trith-saint-léger
dans le nord cette fois les ouvriers
occupent la gare et bloque les trains
denain plusieurs centaines d'ouvriers
occupe 11 aussi la gare de somain et le
centre de triage toujours dans le
valenciennois 2000 sidérurgiste bloquent
la circulation sur l'autoroute a2 et
tout cela s'est passé dans la seule
journée d'aujourd'hui blocus ferroviaire
occupations d'établissements publics
circulation paralysée par tous et
l'opposition à la suppression des 25000
emplois annoncés dans la sidérurgie du
nord-pas-de-calais et de lorraine avec
des formes d'action qui dans certains
cas échappent au contrôle les syndicats
et qui souvent débouche sur la violence
pour tous les observateurs la situation
devient de plus en plus préoccupante et
en une heure et demie de conférence
aujourd'hui françois mitterrand a eu
l'occasion de d'évoquer le problème de
la sidérurgie
pendant sept heures et demie de
conférence de presse françois mitterrand
n'a pas parlé et je vous le signale
d'abord de la compétition pourtant assez
vive à l'intérieur du parti socialiste
devant la presse cet après-midi un seul
grand sujet en fait pour le premier
secrétaire
la condamnation
la politique économique du gouvernement
baptisé plan giscard et les propositions
socialistes pour sortir de la crise un
contre-plan quelque sorte sur la
sidérurgie alors françois mitterrand a
demandé l'arrêt de tous les
licenciements et une négociation entre
eux quatre partenaires l'état les
employeurs les syndicats et les élus des
régions concernées
d'autre part le parti socialiste tiendra
une conférence générale de travail
national bardon de travail sur la crise
de la sidérurgie et ce sera le 10
février le samedi 10 février
je vous propose d'écouter un extrait de
la conférence de presse de françois
mitterrand puis l'analyse de patrice
duhamel le plan giscard est en train de
préparer les conditions d'une faillite
du pays
il réussi ni à rétablir la stabilité des
prix
ni à faire redémarrer la croissance ni
adapté la france aux nouveaux problèmes
du monde et au contraire il fait de la
france un pays exsangue affaibli
inégalitaire il est urgent d'arrêter
cette saignée pour mettre en oeuvre une
nouvelle politique économique
l'inflation reste voisine en france de
10 % alors qu'en europe du marché commun
elles oscillent autour en moyenne de 5%
et descend même à 0 5% en suisse le
chômage continue d'augmenter atteindra
un million et demi de travailleurs la
production industrielle ne dépasse que
de 1% celle de 1974 l'équilibré
extérieur n'est assurée que par la
faiblesse du dollar et la récession de
la demande intérieure
le pouvoir d'achat des salariés décline
on vient de battre le record absolu des
faillites avec plus de 15000 en une
sévère pour la politique économique du
gouvernement vous l'avez entendu
françois mitterrand a donc dressé une
sorte de
réquisitoire annonçant un contre plan
socialiste avec des mesures à court
terme à moyen terme et à long terme pour
la mi-avril au lendemain d'un congrès
qui devra trancher dans le conflit
interne actuelle ces difficultés du ps
n'ont donc curieusement pas été évoquée
par françois mitterrand qui s'est
contenté de rappeler que des troubles
excessif nuirait aux résultats
socialiste pour les prochaines élections
le premier secrétaire avait choisi de ne
rien dire de cette turbulence un
problème secondaire at il précisé et
c'est peut-être avec le souci de mieux
se situer au dessus de la mêlée qu'il
s'est adressé directement au chef de
l'état sur le terrain économique et
qu'il a déjà voulu mobiliser pour les
prochaines élections
les cantonales dans six semaines ce sera
a dit françois mitterrand un vrai
sondage politique
et puis les élections européennes dans
un peu plus de quatre mois et sur ce
point
sa stratégie semble peu à peu se
préciser selon le leader socialiste je
le cite face au double non à l'europe du
pc et du rpr un nom qu'il juge illogique
et incohérent et face aux 800 conditions
de l'udf
les socialistes vont militer pour un oui
assorti de conditions pour
l'élargissement de l'europe à l'espagne
et les socialistes feront campagne pour
l'europe des travailleurs c'est la
formule employée cette élection
européenne on en a eu aussi la
confirmation durcira encore les tensions
avec un parti communiste qui selon
françois mitterrand fait passer
l'intérêt du parti avant l'intérêt des
travailleurs au total le numéro un
socialiste n'a donc pas apporté beaucoup
d'éléments nouveaux
il entendait avant tout et cette
préoccupation était visible s'exprimer
au nom de l'ensemble des socialistes
occulter les querelles ne pas apparaître
comme un leader de tendance alors que
l'heure de vérité approche au ps le
comité directeur du 11 février sera très
important françois mitterrand voulait
renforcer auprès de ses militants
une autorité sans doute atteinte par les
déchirements des dernières semaines y
est il parvenu
la réponse est pour bientôt demain au
conseil des ministres les femmes auront
largement la parole d'abord pour traiter
des problèmes des femmes et de l'action
menée en leur faveur pour rattraper
certaines injustices c'est madame
monique pelletier qui s'en chargera et
les ministres chargés de la condition
féminine
quant à madame nicole pasquet
secrétaires d'état elle ouvrira le
dossier de l'emploi féminin
et puis c'est madame simone weil
ministre de la santé et de la famille
qui traitera d'un sujet bien connu et
qui va rester longtemps à l'ordre du
jour
comment réduire ou en tout cas modérer
les dépenses de l'assurance maladie
vous vous souvenez qu'à la mi-décembre
quand la décision a été prise
d'augmenter les cotisations de la
sécurité sociale madame veil ici même
d'ailleurs avait parlé entre autres de
l'auto discipline indispensable du corps
médical elle avait évoqué la possibilité
de sanctionner les praticiens abusif
même si avait-elle ajouté ces derniers
sont peu nombreux alors voyons où nous
en sommes sur ce point avec daniel bigot
les prestations des médecins c'est en
effet la cible numéro 1 du gouvernement
pour réduire les dépenses de santé
le but est double stopper la
surconsommation des médicaments et faire
la chasse aux ordonnances de
complaisance comment est bien un système
d'auto discipline va être mise en place
avec l'accord des syndicats du corps
médical
dorénavant chaque médecin aura son
dossier ses prestations c'est à dire le
nombre de ces consultations et la
longueur de ces ordonnances seront
comparées chaque année à une moyenne
établie grâce aux statistiques des
caisses d'assurance maladie
dès qu'un médecin s'écartera de trop de
cette moyenne
il sera rappelé à l'ordre par une
commission départementale composée de
responsables médicaux et de la sécurité
sociale en cas de récidive la sanction
ira jusqu'aux des conventionnement du
médecin c'est à dire à la suppression du
remboursement de ses actes
la cible numéro deux les dépenses
d'hospitalisation elles représentent
actuellement plus de la moitié des
dépenses de santé objectif réduire de 3
% les dépenses en trois ans plusieurs
mesures sont à l'étude premièrement
stabilisation voire réduction du nombre
de lits paradoxalement certaines régions
sont suréquipés
deuxièmement limitation de la durée
d'hospitalisation les frais
d'hospitalisation étant calculée à la
journée certains hôpitaux ont tendance à
prolonger inutilement le séjour à
l'hôpital
troisièmement meilleure gestion du
personnel les dépenses du personnel
représentent actuellement 70% des
dépenses hospitalières
en marge de ces mesures d'autres sont en
préparation un projet vise les facultés
de médecine pour une sélection renforcée
des étudiants à la fin de la première
année au rythme actuel en 1982 la france
aura le taux de médecins le plus élevé
d'europe
et puis le second projet vise la
consommation pharmaceutique avec le
lancement d'une campagne d'information
auprès du public
et la limitation de la publicité
pharmaceutique l'enjeu de toutes ces
mesures c'est la survie même du système
de la sécurité sociale qui enregistrera
rappelons le un déficit de 15 milliards
de francs pour 78 et 79 déjà à la mi
décembre le gouvernement a pris une
première série de mesures dont le but
est d'augmenter les recettes
demain il s'attaquera donc aux dépenses
de santé seuls leurs limitations peut
assurer une solution à long terme
mais l'effort à faire est considérable
entre 69 et 77
les dépenses de santé autant augmenté de
18 % chaque année nous avons été au fond
des choses
nos discussions étaient très proches
honnête très cordiale et harmonieuse
nous avons établi des relations pour de
futurs conversations régulières
c'est ce que jimmy carter a dit à propos
de ses entretiens avec le dirigeant
chinois deng xiaoping
vous allez me dire que ses paroles ne
vous apprennent pas grand chose que
c'est toujours ce qu'on dit en pareil
cas c'est toujours france est toujours
honnête c'est toujours cordiales quand
ce n'est pas bénéfique et constructif et
c'était le cas d'ailleurs
mais jimmy carter insiste cette première
visite officielle d'un dirigeant
communiste chinois à washington est l'un
des événements les plus importants de
l'histoire de l'amérique c'est lui qui
le dit jimmy carter c'est vrai en tout
cas qu'on ne mesure pas encore les
conséquences de cette visite officielle
de deng xiaoping alors interrompt jo
jacqueline du bois
l'offensive de charme lancée par les
américains en direction de la chine qui
se fait part à son rôle de grande
puissance se poursuit ici à washington
tout est fait du côté américain pour ne
pas heurter les susceptibilités
chinoises
hier soir avant le dîner de gala il ya
eu un instant de repos ni les américains
ni baguette préparer pour la chine et
l'inde étaient fabriqués à taiwan
il a fallu l'échangé sur la question de
taiwan les chinois sont venus ils savent
que jimmy carter ne reviendra sur ses
décisions
ceux qui souhaitent obtenir maintenant
c'est la technologie et le savoir-faire
américain ainsi que des curés à des taux
raisonnables
je me ferai rentrer lui doit encore
persuader les sénateurs et l'ofii niño
publique américaine il a eu raison de
renouer avec la chine tenus en effet pas
certain d'américains pensent que les
états unis ou tort de livrer leurs
expériences et leurs dernières
découvertes technologiques un pays qui
se réclament toujours du marxisme
léninisme et qui demain pourrait renouer
avec son ennemi d'aujourd'hui le mix qui
aujourd'hui commence le troisième
entretien tant qu'acteur il portera sur
les relations bilatérales
mais l'urss ne sera pas absente de ces
entretiens la possibilité de maintenir
en équilibre entre washington et pékin
et moscou est au centre de tous les
entretiens ici officiellement il n'ya
plus de réfugiés politiques espagnols en
france à compter d'aujourd'hui le
ministère des affaires étrangères a
annoncé la suppression du statut de
réfugié pour les espagnols ceux qui sont
encore titulaire d'une carte de réfugié
se verront accorder automatiquement à la
place les cartes de séjour et de travail
de ressorts de simples ressortissants
espagnols on explique que cette décision
a été prise à la suite de la
démocratisation du régime de madrid avec
la loi d'amnistié générale par exemple
avec l'adoption de sa constitution son
adhésion
les riffs l'adhésion d'espagne à la
convention de genève sur les réfugiés
ici il n'est pas inutile de rappeler que
pendant toute la longue période du
franquisme de nombreux républicains
espagnols ont bénéficié de l'hospitalité
de la france et souvent s'y sont fait
une nouvelle vie la décision
d'aujourd'hui est donc la traduction
juridique de la nouvelle situation en
espagne et des nouvelles relations aussi
de ce pays avec la france couronné par
le voyage du président de la république
en juin dernier selon voilà il ya aussi
le problème basque les attentats
terroristes dont le gouvernement
espagnol fait remarquer qu'il trouvait
que les auteurs de ces attentats
trouvaient des protections au pays
basque français et là on voit que la
décision de supprimer le statut de
réfugié a coïncidé aujourd'hui même avec
l'interpellation dans les pyrénées
atlantiques de très espagnole
susceptibles de créer des troubles dans
leurs pays à l'occasion des prochaines
élections
et puis d'autre part sept autres
ressortissants espagnols qui ne
possédait aucun titre de séjour ont été
refoulés en espagne régis faucon les
mesures l'interpellation prises par les
autorités françaises semblent répondre à
l'impatience pour ne pas dire plus du
gouvernement de madrid face aux
agissements des basques réfugier chez
nous madrid a toujours pensé que paris
n'en faisait pas assez en quelque sorte
surtout en cette période difficile que
traverse l'espagne
celle de la consolidation de la
démocratie
les espagnols estiment que la
persistance de la violence constitue la
plus grande des menaces pour cette
démocratie les militaires et les
policiers acceptant de moins en moins
cette situation le 11 janvier dernier du
ministre espagnol des affaires
étrangères était à paris l'an repartez
avec affirme- t-il certaine assurance
il avait même précisé que la france
était prête à procéder à certaines
expulsions du côté de paris on est
beaucoup plus nuancée on souligne que la
france est le président valéry giscard
d'estaing l'avait dit lors de sa
dernière visite à madrid que la france
ne peut plus considérer les basques
espagnols résidant dans notre pays comme
des réfugiés compte tenu du fait que la
démocratie existe bel et bien désormais
de l'autre côté des pyrénées
ils seront simplement à la même enseigne
que les autres étrangers travaillant en
france bénéficiant des mêmes droits
mes tenues également au respect des
mêmes obligations
après sa visite aux indiens zatopek hier
le pape est arrivé il ya quelques heures
guadalajara à 500 kilomètres de mexico
premier geste pour celui qui a déjà reçu
là bas le surnom de paepe des pauvres et
une visite dans un faubourg très
populaire et très miséreux celui de
sainte cécile jean paul 2 s'est ensuite
rendu dans l'immense stade de la ville
jacques hébert
le football est le sport mexicain de
loin le plus populaire est pourtant
rarement le stade de guadalajara n'aura
été aussi plein qu'aujourd'hui plus de
cent mille personnes venues accueillir
le pape en blanc comme l'appellent les
mexicains au sens de chansons
folkloriques
il fait 30 degrés à guadalajara pour la
première fois depuis six jours
on peut discerner quelques signes de
fatigue sur le visage de jean paul ii il
faut dire que le souverain pontife ne
ménage pas ses efforts et sa santé il a
déjà serré sous une chaleur accablante
plusieurs milliers de mains et cela au
milieu d'une foule presque toujours
proche du délire
au stade de guadalajara sur le milieu du
terrain une immense croix de fleurs
jaunes et blanches et une estrade où le
pape prononcera le 26e discours de son
voyage discours dans lequel le pape
s'adressera plus particulièrement aux
pauvres et aux miséreux
mais la journée du pape il est 7 heures
de moins au mexique en france n'est pas
terminée loin de là dans quelques
instants jean paul ii bénira sur un
circuit intérieur de télévision 3000
prisonniers de droit commun
une messe est également prévue à la
basilique notre-dame de zakopane
le souverain pontife regagnera tard dans
la nuit mexico où il tiendra demain une
conférence de presse avant de s'envoler
pour le vatican le mexique lui a
décidément réservé un accueil plus que
chaleureux
c'est vraiment c'est très très rare
c'est exceptionnel de voir un peuple
prendre ainsi un bain de foule
jean claude narcy les autres nouvelles
de ce journal l'algérie d'abord oui et
qui sera le successeur de houari
boumediene et bien la décision
appartient au congrès du fln réunis
aujourd'hui pour désigner le candidat à
la présidence de la république
mais le nom de ce candidat que nous
attendu en début de soirée n'est pas
encore sortie du congrès les noms les
plus souvent prononcé aider ceux du
colonel bendjedid plus connu sous son
nom de guerre chadli et celui du colonel
el ghallaoui on avait parlé aussi de
monsieur bouteflika ministre des
affaires étrangères donc le nom du
candidat officiel ne sera connue que
fort tard ce soir
moshe dyan qui est allé se recueillir ce
matin au mémorial des martyrs juifs a
été reçu cet après midi par le président
valéry giscard d'estaing
cette visite de décrispation que vient
d'effectuer le ministre des affaires
étrangères israélien s'est achevé ce
soir dans le souci mutuelle d'une
normalisation des rapports franco
israélien à sa sortie de l'elysée
mâchez diana qualifié de cordial et
d'utile sa visite au chef de l'état il
était question du processus de paix au
proche orient et du liban en ce qui
concerne ce dernier point la france se
montre préoccupé de la détérioration de
la situation et des affrontements
monsieur dyan nuit a mis l'accent sur
l'insécurité de la frontière
libano-israélienne ça va mal dans
l'industrie française du poids lourd
après les 950 suppressions d'emplois
décidées en décembre dernier la
direction de renault véhicules
industriels a rendu publique 873 mise à
la retraite anticipée ou départs
volontaires et ce n'est peut-être pas
encore terminée cette série de
dégraissage successives correspond en
fait à une situation bien précises la
fusion entre berliet saviem n'a pas
confirmé les résultats escomptés
les pertes financières sont estimées à
présent à environ 350 millions de francs
cinq élections à des conseils régionaux
aujourd'hui alain savary est réélu à la
présidence du conseil régional de midi
pyrénées et de ghardaïa des réélus dans
le languedoc roussillon
pierre chier les réélu au conseil
régional d'alsace jean delannoy est élu
président du conseil régional de la
région centre en remplacement de
monsieur pierre sudreau enfin michel
giraud a été réélu président du conseil
régional d'ile-de-france police en 1979
25 % de son parc auto sera renouvelée un
effort sera également accompli pour
améliorer l'infrastructure l'armement et
des liaisons
radio c'est la promesse faite par le
ministre de l'intérieur qui a passé la
nuit dans divers commissariats de la
police de la région parisienne christian
bonnet à effectuer cette tournée
surprise pour se rendre compte des
conditions de travail des gardiens de la
paix et les inspecteurs chargés de la
sécurité
le dialogue dit on a été souvent
passionnées les cendres de nelson
rockefeller ancien vice président des
états unis décédé vendredi dernier à new
york ont été déposées au cimetière de
tarrytown dans l'état de new york
seule la proche famille assister à cette
cérémonie le corps de l'ancien
gouverneur de new york avait été
incinéré dimanche matin séisme à new
york un tremblement de terre a secoué
aujourd'hui le faubourg new yorkais de
statham island et une partie de l'état
du new jersey on ignore pour le moment
si ce séisme a fait des victimes
j'ai eu l'impression qu'on arrache et
l'immeuble de ses fondations a déclaré
un policier qui se trouvait sur place
commission d' enquête décidée par le
ministère des transports à la suite de
l'accident du fokker dr1 rouergue qui
coûta la vie à cinq des six passagers
lors d'un vol d'essai près de rodez vive
émotion en alsace après la nouvelle
programmation du musée de la déportation
au camp de struthof dans le bas rhin
c'est la deuxième fois en trois ans et
le conseil général dénonce aujourd'hui
cet acte odieux qui dans un communiqué
s'inscrit dans une large campagne
tendant à faire disparaître quelques
souvenir des déportés des camps de la
mort et de son côté le secrétaire d'état
aux anciens combattants
maurice plantier a demandé au ministre
de l'intérieur que tous les moyens
soient trouvé afin d'arrêter cette
escalade du vandalisme sacrilège le
temps vient des hauts et des bas
aujourd'hui dans les températures débat
dans le sud-ouest 3 degrés seulement à
pau hier y faisait 13 je crois mais une
confirmation de températures clémentes
dans le nord de la france en tout cas
dans la région parisienne notamment
demain après de faibles gelées et
quelques brouillards givrants dans
l'intérieur il y aura alternance de
nuages et d'éclaircies
quelques averses sur l'est des pluies
aussi de la manche à la belgique et au
bassin parisien
en tout cas un ciel couvert et un climat
plutôt médiocre pour finir on a rarement
l'occasion de parler des archives
nationales il n'y a que les initiés de
la culture et de l'histoire qui
connaissent pas le grand public
pourtant chaque année on y réalise
de passionnante exposition les plus
récentes sur louis philippe sur le
parisien du 19e siècle ou sur
s'entendent république
ce matin c'est le musée de l'histoire de
france que le président de la république
a inauguré aux archives nationales
toujours la grande salle a été
entièrement renouvelée dans la
préparation dans la présentation par
dont on y trouve 71 documents originaux
qui vont du roi dagobert à jean moulin
en passant par la fameuse déclaration
des droits de l'homme
il faut rappeler que les archives
nationales furent créés par l'assemblée
constituante pour conserver tout ce qui
concernait la révolution au palais rohan
soubise
par la suite on n'y a déposé tous les
écrits important des républiques et des
monarchies et au cours de cette visite
aujourd'hui monsieur giscard d'estaing a
même annoncé qu'il allait créer des
archives présidentielles afin que tous
les dossiers importants traités par
l'elysée puisse être placé robert werner
a visité pour nous le musée de
l'histoire de france
dagobert
vous l'ignoriez a laissé un écrit en
mérovingiens ce roi d'austrasie et dans
la capitale et ms gratifie sur ce
document en papyrus de 623 un partage de
terre entre deux personnes
la langue d'oc était celle du sud la
langue d'oil celle du nord ici vous
voyez un document exceptionnel tout en
languedoc il à 880 ans c'est un serment
de fidélité
prêté à raymond saint gilles la en
langue d'oil et de la même époque
c'est un tarif de péage déjà en payer
une taxe pour toute marchandise
transportée une sorte de tva avant la
lettre
philippe le bel annonce qu'il doit
altérer la monnaie en diminuant son toit
ces guerres contre les flammes en lui en
coûtait trop cher c'est une dévaluation
ses successeurs auront très bien compris
la formule ses cachets sont ceux des
villes qui répondent à l'appel du roi
contre le pape boniface 8 qui voulait un
droit de surveillance sur le royaume
jeanne d'arc pointe au 15e siècle il est
vrai et non à son époque écrit aux
habitants de race que le roi de france
charles vii sera bientôt à paris quant à
henri viii d'angleterre
il a pris boulogne ce roi promet de
rendre la ville contre 800 mille écus en
huit ans il à rendre à quatre ans plus
tard déjà pour moitié prix il avait
besoin d'argent
louis xiv fait sans testament en faveur
du dauphin et le signe et même deux fois
pour être plus sûre pour l'appliquera il
nomme le père letellier comme futur
confesseur mais à peine enterrée et
malgré l'archevêque caricaturer ici que
duc d'orléans fera qu'assez le testament
et prendra la régence ici l'original de
la déclaration des droits de l'homme
louis saez douala signé mais il n'est
pas chaud trente mille femmes vont à
versailles et l'amène de tuilerie
il écrira j'accepte purement et
simplement ses droits de l'homme comme
présente c'est signé louis 5 octobre
1789 napoléon fatigué pictave bourgault
à sainte hélène
je veux reposer sur les bords de seine
auprès de ce peuple de france que j'ai
tant aimé
c'est la première loi sociale elle dit
il est interdit d'envoyer des enfants de
moins de 8 ans de 8 à 12 ans c'était
huit heures de travail de 12 à 16 ans il
ne fallait pas plus de douze heures la
commune et louise michel qui écrit un
poème les oeillets rouges à un condamné
à mort et sur un faire-part s'est
adressé à théophile ferrer communards à
la prison de versailles
il est exécuté peu après en octobre 71
ce rapport enfin et de jean moulin
préfet d'eure-et-loir en juillet 40
il rend compte ministre de l'intérieur
des attaques allemandes sur sa région le
musée de l'histoire de france qui
s'ouvre aujourd'hui fait revivre un
passé de plusieurs siècles tous
captivant voilà merci robert werner
c'était très passionnant bonne soirée à
tous et à toutes au nom de toute
l'équipe de tf1 actualité dernier
journal jacques le noir 23h15
merci